Speaker 1: OK, one other quick story here. We
now have an actual poll. What did people think
of Joe Biden's first official State of the Union
address on Tuesday? Remember, I gave it a b,
and I thought there were some good parts and some
not so good parts. Almost 80 percent of those who
watched it believe that Joe Biden was on point and
approve of his remarks. This is surprising even to
me, quite frankly. Nearly eight in 10 of State of
the Union watchers approve of Joe Biden's remarks.
78 percent in a new CBS YouGov poll said that they
approve of Biden's remarks. Twenty two percent
disapproved. Those surveys surveyed were also
asked to check all of the feelings that applied to
them. And many said they came away with positive
feelings. 67 percent said they were optimistic.
Fifty percent said they felt proud. Only
20 percent said they were pessimistic and
13 percent angry. Now you have to consider that
it is. This is of people who watched and quite
certainly because it's a Democratic president.
More of those who watched may indeed be Democrats.
But there's also a CNN poll conducted by SARS,
which said 71 percent had a positive reaction,
although again, friendlier audiences.
More Democrats than Republicans tend
to be attracted to these speeches. A couple of
different notes here number one. Some of these
Insta polls online, yeah, there's a
lot of right wingers will say, Whoa,
look at this 40. Only 48 percent liked the speech.
Understand that those Insta polls are worth
the gum on the pre chewed gum on the bottom of
your shoe. The really worth nothing. Anybody,
whether you saw the speech or not, can weigh
in. And even people who might have thought the
speech was OK will just lie on those. Those are
notoriously not accurate. We really should be
looking at actual polling. A couple different
thoughts. One. There may be a little bit of a
rally around the flag going on the Ukrainian flag,
and we know in general approval for presidents and
approval for speeches like these tend to be higher
when there is such a conflict. In this case,
it's a conflict elsewhere, but it's one that most
of the world is united in terms of who should we
be supporting here? And that was the strongest
part of Biden's speech, the part about Ukraine.
So that may certainly be a factor. The other
thing is it's I always like to be reminded
that my interpretation of these things is very
different than people who don't follow this stuff
as closely. And I think it's a good reminder for
all of us because even people who listen to shows
like mine are probably not like the average and
that most people don't listen to political stuff
or follow politics as closely as you do who if
you're watching this clip or listening today,
you are not likely the sort of average person.
And although I gave it a B and thought it had
a lot of weak moments, clearly those who watched
it had a much better impression. And I think that
that's interesting for us to keep in mind
particularly interesting. I mean, listen,
I gave it a B and said it had some good parts.
People like Ben Shapiro said this is essentially
the worst speech ever. It was pathetic. It was out
of touch. It was filled with lies and rambling,
and Biden was confused. You didn't know what was
going on. Very few people who watched it came away
with that impression, either. A lot of the focus
online has been, Oh, Biden meant to say Ukrainian,
and he said Iranian. But the average person
who watched it is not even thinking about that,
and that's an important reminder for us as well.
So a well-received speech. The question now will
be and Monday will look at this. Does Joe
Biden's approval rating recover because it's
essentially at his presidency low? Will will this
speech help him recover? We will see. We'll have
clips from these segments on our Instagram,
which you can find at The David Pakman Show.